nous sommes au cern le centre européen
pour la recherche nucléaire à cheval
entre la france et la suisse
et c'est dans ce bureau un peu neutre
que tout a commencé il ya 30 ans mais
depuis beaucoup de choses ont changé
effectivement on se demande sont à part
finalement créé un monstre
aujourd'hui hors de contrôle le monstre
au début il ressemblait à ça ou plutôt
même à ceux spaghetti comment l'idée
at-elle germé en 1989
est ce que l'objectif était mondiale
alors pour démêler ses racines du web on
va demander son avis à quelqu'un qu'il
explore de fond en comble tous les jours
d'abord le web ce n'est pas internet
internet faut vraiment le voir comme des
tuyaux et le web serment une application
qui se dépose sur ses tuyaux là qui
existait quand même à l'époque depuis 20
ans avec un ordinateur qu'il introduit
en douce
tim berners lee n'a qu'une envie rendre
plus accessibles toute l'information
produite par ses collègues
sa proposition c'est gestion de
l'information deux points d'une
proposition et il marque fender qui est
allé de son mot qui est demeurée célèbre
ses îles et écrivaine bottes exciting
mais ce qu'on sait moins c'est qu'à la
fin du document il a rajouté une petite
question toute courte à la fin de la
proposition de tim berners lee cn n'a
point d'interrogation et ensuite des
sites internet plus ou moins réussies
des cybercafés caramail myspace youtube
google facebook et surtout la moitié de
la planète connectés ce qui fait dire
aux créateurs des artistes et kz2 ya que
deux choses à faire il faut connecter
l'autre moitié parce que c'est injuste
bout et ceux qui sont en ligne
ce n'est pas vraiment le web qu'on avait
imaginé
c'est sûr que c'est pas un beau 30e
entre extérieur web qui est un ado qui
est extrêmement quête en révolte et qui
se fait utiliser aussi un peu à son insu
par des forces qu'il ne comprend pas des
forces du
on de cambridge analytique par exemple
une dérive où les utilisateurs du web
sont devenus des produits mais il ya
toujours du bon sur le web ça par
exemple alors c'est si c'est le premier
matin dans la cherche
lancé en 1990 allons voir à quoi aurait
ressemblé le site de radio canada
c'est en noir et blanc y'a pas de stage
vient pas de couleur donc on focalise
sur l'information
seulement ça mais tu prostré du canada
montréal